[Music]
to introduce James I don't know how many
people were here last week for aerial
Waldman's talk on the future of human
space travel there there are a few in
here great so this is a really
interesting talk in the wake of that
because Ariel was talking about how
we're going out into the universe about
the technology the machines that we need
to build to go out and explore further
outward what James's book and the the
people he documents in deep are finding
things deeper within this planet finding
things below and actually not just using
technology but actually finding things
within themselves to be able to explore
deeper into this planet so we've got an
amazing hour in front of us let's give a
big round of applause to James to get
that start
[Applause]
thanks a lot
about ten years ago my friend Steve
called me up and said hey man do you
want to go to this lecture some
astronauts gonna be speaking about how
an asteroids gonna hit the earth and
we're all gonna die
and I thought awesome astronauts
asteroids space post apocalyptic
prophecies I'm in that was one of the
first ever long now seminars and was
right over there in the Presidio and
since then I've been to literally dozens
and dozens of these things so it's
really thrilling for me to be here and
giving you all my my own personal post
apocalyptic prophecy tonight so I'm
gonna give you a little review on what
you're gonna be seeing here about
two-and-a-half years ago I was sent by
outside magazine to cover something
called the world free diving
championships now this is a very weird
competition where people test each other
to see how deep they can dive on a
single breath of air and I didn't know
too much about free diving hadn't done
it didn't know anyone who had I remember
being out there in Greece it was held in
the deep waters and kalamata Greece
outside of the marina and being on this
platform and watching this guy take a
single breath of air up turning his body
and sinking and sinking some more and
sinking some more until I couldn't see
him four minutes later he came back up
he had just swum 335 feet on one breath
of air now I thought it was totally
impossible I had no idea the human body
was capable of diving to such depths so
for a minute I thought wow there must be
an air tank down there so I checked that
out online and found if there had been
an air tank and if he would have
actually breathed some of that air his
lungs would have exploded as he ascended
to the shallower depths he would have
died it's only the human body in its
natural form can we withstand a fast
300-foot underwater ascent so I started
checking out some more information and
found out that
not only do humans share these
amphibious reflexes with whales dolphins
and other marine mammals but we also
share a number of other extra senses
with these animals that help them
navigate through a dark cold environment
humans have those too that's what I
ended up writing this book about and
that's what the rest of this
presentation is about so the second we
put our faces in water something amazing
happens your heart rate starts to lower
about 25% of its normal resting rate
blood starts rushing from your
extremities into your core your brain
waves soften you enter this very
meditative state the deeper you go into
the water these reflexes will react more
and more until a very deep depths you
resemble only a passing resemblance to
your terrestrial form scientists call
this transformation the mammalian dive
reflex or more lyrically the master
switch of life and they've been
researching it for about 50 years and
the term master switch of life describes
not one but many reflexes that affect
the brain lungs and other organs that
work in concert with a bunch of other
reflexes and senses within us to protect
us from the immense underwater pressure
of a deep dive they essentially turn us
into deep-sea diving
animals now ancient cultures knew all
about the master switch and used it for
centuries to harvest sponges pearls and
food thousands or hundreds of feet below
the ocean surface certain sailors that
went out to the South Pacific and Japan
reported seeing divers dive down about
150 feet and stay down there for 15
minutes at a time on a single breath now
I know what you're thinking that sounds
totally impossible and all of the
scientists that heard these reports
consider them either fallacious or
complete exaggerations they didn't
believe him even up until the 1950s
scientists said the deepest a human
could dive in the water and survive was
about
100 feet any deeper and her lungs would
collapse well today free divers are
diving to depths of 700 feet on a single
breath of air and the longest breath old
underwater is 12 minutes and 30 seconds
so that's just two and a half minutes
short of these made-up reports by these
ancient sailors and consider we haven't
been doing this for that long
competitive diving has really only been
going on for about 15 years so in a
matter of years maybe five maybe seven
maybe even sooner we'll be diving down
to 1,000 feet and holding our breath for
over 15 minutes now I know what you're
thinking
how is that possible how can the human
body survive and depths that are 30
times that of the surface well in water
the deeper we go the more pressure
increases and the more air contracts sea
water is 800 times denser than air so
this pressure increase happens very
quickly a dive down just to 10 feet is
equivalent to diving down an atmosphere
10,000 feet instead of a bag of chips
you know when you're driving up to the
mountains or boarding a plane bag of
chips will inflate well everything in
the ocean deflates the lower and lower
you go even human lungs so human lungs
at 33 feet will be half their volume at
66 feet they will be 1/3 of their volume
at 99 feet 1/4 of their volume and on
and on and on so you can imagine how
small they would be at 300 feet the
equivalent pressures of a deep dive down
to those depths would probably injure or
kill us but not in the ocean because we
all came from the ocean and each of us
literally has an ocean within us human
blood holds about a 98% similar chemical
composition to seawater we're only
missing a molecule of iron seawater is
missing a molecule of magnesium the
human fetus seen here develops in an
amniotic fluid that's about 99% similar
to seawater
our first characteristics are fish like
we grow fins first instead of feet and
our one misfiring gene away from growing
fence instead of feet or hands were born
to dive the human infant when placed in
water can hold his or her breath
comfortably for about 45 seconds at a
time and she'll begin breast wroking
like this little person and open her
eyes and they're very comfortable in
water and we only lose this ability when
we're taught how to walk but we're
gaining it as you will soon see it's
pretty easy what I'm going to show you
now is a free dive by a French diver
named gr me Neary this has been viewed
about 20 million times on YouTube
so the second Neary goes in the water
something amazing happens his heart rate
is gonna lower blood is gonna start
rushing from his extremities he's gonna
enter this very mellow space at around
35 feet that's where he is now he's
gonna enter something called neutral
buoyancy where the water is no longer
going to be pushing him up towards the
surface as it would in a swimming pool
but it's gonna start sucking him down
deeper and deeper and will keep sucking
him down this video is supposed to be in
real-time so if you get bored during
this talk you can try to hold your
breath as long as he's going to right
now so you're gonna see he's gonna hop
off this cliff here and he's not gonna
kick his legs he's not gonna move his
arms he's just gonna effortlessly float
down this isn't a video trick this is
what happens at this depth something
freediver is called the doorway to the
deep what everything reverses everything
changes at around a hundred and fifty
feet his lungs will be about the size of
two baseballs and his heart rate will
lower even more free divers have
recorded heart rates as low as 14 beats
per minute that's about a third of a
person in a coma and some free divers
have recorded heart rates as low as
seven beats per minute now according to
our understanding of human physiology
that's totally impossible that shouldn't
be able to support consciousness
and yet deep in the ocean it does and
still no one knows exactly how so he's a
protein about 300 feet and this is when
the master switch really starts kicking
in blood is gonna start passing through
his organs and the alveoli in his lungs
will engorge with blood to keep them
from collapsing these reflexes only
happen in deep water it's the only way
to trigger them and we all have them so
his body isn't really anything special
all our bodies would be doing the same
thing his is doing at this depth so as
he dives even deeper something called
the spleen release happens this usually
only happens during times of shock when
you get in an accident the body
reflexively releases new oxygenated
blood into the bloodstream but it also
happens in deep diving and free divers
like Neary use this as a turbo charge to
dive even deeper so he's reached the
very bottom now is the really hard part
he needs to make it back up and still be
conscious but you can see he's very
experienced at what he's doing he is
French so he's doing a little French
miming hair for you he's in the
invisible box and he's he's back up and
since the ocean is pushing against him
he can literally crawl up this cliff as
though he were crawling up it in regular
air it just takes a lot longer as he
continues to go up
all of those master switches within him
are reversing so his mind will wake up
his heart rate will speed up all of the
blood within his core will begin pushing
out to his extremities the human body in
its natural form can't get the bends
when they're diving on your own power
that only happens to scuba divers we
know how to process that exchange of
nitrogen gas as you see as he approaches
he's gonna purge all that nitrogen gas
from his body take a big deep breath and
get ready to do it over again so that is
the master switch of life we are not the
only ones to have the mass
switch many marine mammals also have it
seals dolphins whales use the master
switch to dive to depths much deeper
than we can this guy the Weddell seal
can dive down 2500 feet and hold his
breath for 60 minutes at a time now
researchers who were studying these
seals in the sixties found that they
actually seemed to gain oxygen the
deeper they dove now everything we know
about physics and mammal physiology says
that's impossible they can't gain oxygen
these guys don't really care about our
rules they do it all the time they come
up perfectly healthy and they've
probably been doing it for about a
hundred thousand years so we have more
in common than just the master switch
with oceanic animals
we also share many of these extra senses
that I was talking about to survive in a
lightless cold and pressurized
environment animals need extra senses to
navigate communicate and see what good
our eyes when you're in complete
blackness all the time you need another
way of getting around in humans many of
these senses are latent and mostly
unused but that doesn't mean they've
gone away we still have them and with a
little practice we can reengage them the
first of these I'm going to talk about
is magnetic reception now we've been
taught that animals have five senses
with which we can view the world or
perceive the world taste touch smell
sight and hearing
but the problem is an attractor so ssin
what good is sight again when you're
cruising around migrating from one
island thousands of miles away and back
again it's of no use
so they have to be using something else
researchers in the 60s were wondering
how these animals were able to to
migrate in these amazing patterns and
they started putting satellite
transmitters on sharks what they found
was amazing sharks were migrating
hundreds of miles from one island to the
other
and back again but what was even more
amazing as they were doing so in
perfectly straight line
which is a really hard thing to do when
you're dealing with ocean currents and
you're not able to see anything so at
the same time that marine researchers
were looking at these sharks and
wondering what was going on a German
zoologist by the name of Frederick
Merkel started noticing some pretty
peculiar behavior with European Robins
this is a European Robin he noticed that
in the fall the Robins always hopped
south in the spring they always hop
north so even in enclosed rooms when
they couldn't access the Sun or the
Stars they would always hop in these
directions so Merkel did what many good
scientists before him have done and he
started running some pretty weird
experiments he got each of these
European Robins got a bunch of them put
them in a bucket
turn the bucket upside down and on the
floor of that bucket was a little touch
sensitive pad that would record what
direction the Robins would be facing in
in inside of this bucket where obviously
it was pitch black he did this over
several months and the results were
always the same and spring they would
always be facing north in fall it would
always be facing south in other words
this was the exact same direction
the Robins would be flying in during
their normal migration patterns they
were hardwired to be facing in these
directions and they always faced in
these directions with one exception when
he put the Robin's in a magnetically
shielded chamber this is what happened
to their sense of hopping and their
sense of direction it totally
disappeared so what was interesting is
the scientists that saw Merkel's studies
and talked to him about it thought he
was a complete fraud they said this is
pseudoscience they called his studies a
complete sham 20 years later what did we
discover that not only birds but a host
of other animals like even bacteria has
a magnetic sense so Merkel was right
researchers believe that all of these
animals are able to home in on the
subtle energy the Earth's magnetic field
which is pictured here and they're able
to use this energy as a kind of natural
GPS to find their way around the globe I
actually just got this tattooed on my
back a couple of days ago just to remind
me so now I'm gonna show you something
else in 2003 I believe it was some
researchers attached a satellite tag to
a great white shark named Nicole three
months later
this tag came off and the researchers
uploaded all the data and they were able
to see where Nicole swam how far how
deep and all that what they found was
amazing Nicole swam 7,000 miles within
three months that's pretty good but what
was even more amazing is she followed a
straight line from South Africa to
Australia and six months after that the
researchers were in South Africa at the
exact same beach where they had tagged
Nicole and who did they see Nicole she
had swam back probably following that
same tract so how is this possible
many researchers believe that these
little dots on the shark's nose and have
something to do with it these are called
ampullae of Lorenzini and sharks have
about 1500 of these and they're
sensitive to the slightest change in
electric fields they allow sharks a
remarkably acute electroreceptive sense
of everything around them great white
sharks are able to sense electrical
fields as small as 125 millionth of a
volt these guys the bonnethead sharks
are able to detect electrical fields as
small as one billionth of a volt just to
put this into perspective for you man I
was holding a one-and-a-half volt
battery one of those batteries that you
put into a camera when the teeny ones
and I ran 400 miles of wire from this
battery down to Los Angeles this shark
could sense the electrical field off of
that battery 400 miles away so this
sense is five million times more
sensitive than any human sense and is by
far the most sensitive sense we've ever
discovered on the planet
so next time you're swimming at the
dolphin Club you can remember that
sharks aren't really smelling you there
honing in on your electro receptive
field that is coming off of your heart
and brain waves so it was a pretty
frightening thought when I learned that
as I surf down at Ocean Beach all the
time so anyway sharks do it bees do it
birds do it we probably do it too
humans have probably using have been
using some sort of magnetic cept of
scents for centuries ancient Polynesian
sailors could navigate hundreds of miles
across the open ocean and usually always
make it back to the same exact spot now
they could use celestial navigation for
some of the time solar navigation for
some of that other time but they
couldn't use both all of the time
especially during stormy weather so how
did they do it then there's these guys
the googoo Emma thir and Australian
Aboriginal tribe they incorporated
cardinal directions into their language
they didn't have words for right left
forward or backwards but they did have
words for north south east and west if
one of these guys wanted you to make
room for him on a bench he wouldn't ask
you to move over to the right he would
ask you to move south
they didn't bend backwards they meant
eastwards or northwards so the only way
this group could communicate was if they
knew their exact position on the globe
at all times which is a very hard thing
to do at night and a very hard thing to
do in an enclosed space but they weren't
alone dozens and dozens of cultures also
used cardinal languages just like these
guys
the chech all of central Mexico they
again didn't have words for right or
left but they had words for north south
east and west
in the 1990s a bunch of research
took one of these Ketchel speakers and
placed him in a room they blindfolded
him and they spun him around about 25
times and immediately asked him to
identify where north south east and west
was this guy did it without any
hesitation 20 times in a row and I think
they just gave up and moved on after
that so you know thank God for the 70s
here's a here's a picture from some 70s
experiments in the 70s and 80s human
magnetic reception was all the rage they
conducted over 1,000 experiments in this
stuff and almost all the time people who
were blindfolded twisted around magnets
on their head whatever they were able to
point in their home direction with one
exception when the experimenters would
tape a little piece of magnetite to
their foreheads they lost all sense of
direction now researchers had done this
years before they had taken a turtle and
they had taken a bird and taped I'm not
talking about a kitchen magnet I'm
talking about a teeny teeny piece and
it's really sad if you ever see these
videos because turtles just kind of swim
in circles lazily they have no idea how
to make their way around
so something was interesting I saw a
couple days ago that the Nobel Prize in
science just went to some researchers
that identified something called the
internal GPS within cells this these
cells are able to activate and stay
activated only when an animal is facing
in one particular direction which is how
we're able to find our way around and
remember where we've gone we don't know
if these cells are banged narrow
receptive yet but it makes sense that
they would be there doing more research
in that so I know what you're thinking
is like it seems impossible that we
would have the sense when we can't find
our way out of a shopping mall or a
parking lot the fact is we just don't
need it today too much but we did need
it about 400 years ago and before then
this is what Manhattan was supposed to
look like about 400 years ago you need a
pretty good sense of direction to make
it through here and especially through
the heavily forested areas this is what
hatton looks like now you need zero
sense of direction to make it around
here
the pattern of settlement roads and
other landmarks that under grid our
modern society make it easy to know
exactly where we are
and of course ever we're in doubt you
pull out your phone from practically
anywhere on the planet you can see
exactly where you are through GPS so our
keen sense of magnetic reception has
probably become latent and mostly
dormant just like our need to free dive
to the seafloor and grab food but that
doesn't mean it's gone away it's
probably easy to revive it if you really
want to just close your eyes let your
body do the rest the last thing I'm
gonna talk about is echo location this
is not so much a extrasensory ability as
it is a very acute sense of hearing
now dolphins and whales use echolocation
to see with sound better than we can see
with our eyes a dolphin can sense a rice
grain from 230 feet away with
echolocation and a sperm whale can see
human in water from a mile away
echolocation is so powerful in these
animals that it can penetrate through
flesh and give them a view to what's
inside of the things around them they
essentially have x-ray vision and this
is just an animation of a sperm whale
using echolocation and looking at
everything around him now we're not that
good at echolocation but we are pretty
good this guy is Brian Bush way he's
completely blind he lost his eyesight
when he was 14 years old I'm not talking
legally blind he has zero optic nerves
he can't see but he is taught himself
echolocation the same echolocation that
whales and dolphins and even bats use to
see in his surroundings he is able to
ride his bike through busy city streets
by clicking and listening for the echoes
of those clicks
processing where everything is around
him he goes camping alone in the woods
for weeks at a time when I was with him
he could tell the difference between a
tennis ball and a Rubik's Cube from
across a dining room table just by
clicking when researchers took Bush way
and some other human echo locators and
put him in an fMRI and it looked at
their brains as they echo located they
found that the visual cortex started
lighting up to the researchers there was
no difference from what a bush way and
the other human echo locators were seen
with sounds as it is what we were seeing
with their eyes so different frequencies
they were just processing them in the
same way so we're pretty good but we're
nowhere near as good as the sperm whale
the clicks that human echo locators emit
are about 60 decibels the sperm whale
can click at about 230 6 decibels it's
the loudest animal on the planet
sperm whales can hear each other in the
ocean from hundreds even thousands of
miles away some researchers believe that
they're able to keep in contact with one
another through these clicks on other
sides of the planet these clicks are so
powerful in the water that they can blow
out your eardrums easily and they could
actually vibrate a human body to death
so when you're diving with them it's a
little sketchy
what I'm gonna show you now is a video
of some free divers that I ended up
hanging out with I wasn't with them
during this expedition but I was about
six months later we went on a trip
together and I had the same experience
so of the clicks you're gonna be hearing
are not coming from a boat they aren't
coming from a camera these are the
whales clicking these guys literally
from the inside out to see what they're
all about and the clicks were so
powerful that one of these guys put out
his hand to stop a whale from running
into him and his hand actually was
paralyzed for about four hours
afterwards so he learned not to keep out
his hand in front of him when he was
diving this is an emerging discipline of
research and it's pretty sketchy but um
this is what it's like I'm not going to
talk over this we're gonna play this
kind of loud so you can really get an
experience of what this is all about
okay so I know what you're thinking
why the hell would anyone want to do
that I know that was pretty loud for all
of us but trust me in the water it's
like four million times louder and once
you're hanging out with the whales for a
long time this didn't happen to me but
it happened to these guys their bodies
started heating up from being pelleted
with all of that energy after a while so
again this is pretty sketchy stuff
it's strange to do but it's important to
note that these guys are fascinated by
whales they don't necessarily want to
free dive with them this closely but
they have to because it turns out the
only way to really study these animals
up close is by free diving with them by
approaching them in your natural form
and interacting with them in that way
scuba doesn't work it's too loud
submarines don't work same thing robots
don't work they freak them out but when
you free dive with them if this amazing
paradigm shift occurs and they not only
don't swim away but most of the time the
whales will turn around and welcome you
into the pod and sometimes they orient
themselves vertically and do this very
weird sort of new-age thing around you
as their
as they're flicking it's extremely
intense so the next question you're
probably asking yourself is like why
research sperm wells well it turns out
that those clicks you heard they aren't
just used for echolocation sperm whales
and dolphins also use clicks for
communication and inside of those clicks
is probably one of the most
sophisticated forms of communication
we've discovered on the planet could be
more sophisticated than human language
now I know that sounds completely nuts
to all of you and it certainly sounded
nuts to me when I first started
researching this stuff a couple of years
ago but just consider a couple things
the sperm whale brain is about six times
the size of ours this is a picture of
sperm whales facing us head-on and that
top thing is their nose and behind that
is their brain now sperm whales also
have a neocortex in humans the neocortex
is believed to govern higher level
functions like conscious thought future
planning and language well sperm whales
not only have a neocortex but their's is
about six times the size of ours
sperm whales also have spindle cells
these are long and highly developed
brain structures that neurologists have
associated with compassion love
suffering and you guessed it speech all
of those things that make humans human
and separate us from great apes
well sperm was not only have spindle
cells but have them in a far larger
quantity than we do and they've had them
for 15 million years longer than we have
so why do they have such an evolved
brain why do they have a neocortex why
do they have spindle cells what are they
doing when they float side by side and
communicate with each other back and
forth like this again these aren't
echolocation clicks these are
communication clicks and when you free
dive with them they first pepper you
with echolocation clicks and then they
start sending you communication clicks
they
are trying to contact us in some way we
know they're talking we just don't know
what they're saying but hopefully in the
next few years of freediving marine
research we just might all of the
sounded pretty nuts to me a couple of
years ago when I first met these guys
but after seeing it myself and seeing
the data they were collecting I realized
this may actually be an attainable goal
to try to make contact with these
animals the reality is now I don't think
we really have time to doubt these kind
of bold brave outlyer groups doing this
kind of research the fact of the matter
is we're running out of time the ocean
is changing the seas are rising
90% of coral reefs and the Caribbean are
dead and they're not coming back I heard
that about 50% of the Great Barrier Reef
is dead and it's probably not coming
back a hundred million sharks are killed
every year their stocks probably aren't
coming back so environmental hazards on
the open sea like oil spills trash sound
pollution nuclear waste all of this or
some of this is killing whales and
dolphins and species we don't even know
about yet so these animals may be gone
before we have a chance to fully grasp
their amazing abilities and whatever we
learn about them will lead us inevitably
back to ourselves over the past couple
years of free diving with these
researchers free diving with these
animals learning about my body's own and
fibia SRI flexes and magnetic reception
and echolocation it's become clear to me
that we don't quite know what we are yet
and what our potential is we don't know
what we've come from what we are now or
what will evolve to in the next 10,000
years so applying the many mysteries
still untapped below the ocean surface
seems like a pretty good place to start
looking for answers thank you very much
for coming down tonight appreciate it
[Applause]
questions I wanted to start off with art
so were you so I think of this story as
you came in as a skeptic and went native
so you you didn't know you're gonna do
were you a diver beforehand just had you
done I have I had done scuba diving I
have been next to the ocean my whole
life and so I've been surfing forever
I've been swimming in the ocean forever
but I've spent all of my time at the
surface I never really bothered to look
below that so this was my first foray
into that underwater world yeah and what
was what was it like on your sceptical
journey on your journalist journey to to
see these things that seemed like they
weren't real and how what was the most
challenging to actually accept I mean
did you did you or did you quickly kind
of convert to what I guess all these
things are realer or were there things
that were harder for you to accept and
what evidence convinced you well you can
only listen to people talking about
these experiences for so long and you
can only take what they're saying with
you know certain grain of salt you want
to believe them but you also want to
experience it yourself so I had no
intention of freediving when I first
started this research I just wanted to
write about these guys write about their
research and to sort of see the science
and what they were doing but it became
very obvious very quickly that if I was
ever gonna truly understand what they
were doing if I was ever gonna truly
understand some of the things they were
talking about I had to get in the water
with them and so that's kind of one
thing led to the other and I ended up
becoming a free diver and learning how
to do this along with them and you know
but also you see something like that
whale footage and it makes you a little
apprehensive whales have sperm whales
have eight inch long teeth they usually
eat 60 foot long squid so they could
chop us like in a millisecond but they
don't and that was really interesting to
ponder why they aren't eating us why
they're communicating with us
and and how long did it take to learn
freediving what was that it took me
forever because I had been exposed to
free diving through only competitive
diving so at Greece I mean I was
mystified seeing someone dive down 300
feet but I saw a guy go into cardiac
arrest
not make it up to the surface I saw
people come up with blood all over the
faces I thought was the most insane and
ridiculous sport sport I'd ever seen in
my life
but luckily while I was there I met all
of these guys much more philosophical
spiritual science-based researchers who
are using free diving to apply something
else other than a competition and we're
using it for science and for a greater
good and that's who I ended up hanging
out with and spending all my time with
so there's a little bit of don't try
this at home
involved it's it's there's it takes well
you know these competitive guys they
will dive past the point where their
body tells them to stop free diving is a
very it's very common sense your body
lets you know it has various triggers
that let you know hey maybe you should
get up and grab a breath of air in
competitive diving you learn to turn
those natural triggers off which by
nature is very dangerous so I listen to
those and any reasonable free diver is
gonna listen to those and in that regard
if you do this responsibly and if you
don't take it as a competition but
understand it is more of a meditation or
yogic practice it can be a very safe
thing never do it alone always do it
with someone so alright what's who's got
a question out there on the stairs yes
shallow water blackout
oh ok ok so what what is shallow water
blackout ok um what what happens when
you go deeper and deeper in the water
your lungs shrink
well they reinflates as you come back up
but there isn't enough oxygen in your
blood to pull from your blood and
reinflates the lungs so it creates a
vacuum within your lungs within your
chest and there's a reason why Neri
expelled all of his air at around 12
feet that's when the greatest pressure
happens in the ocean and so you have to
expel all your air at that time a
shallow water blackout is is a serious
danger to people who push beyond their
boundaries and it can happen to anyone
if you if you keep pushing over and over
the physics of it are very complicated
that's that those are the basics of what
happens to in a shallow water blackout
but that's another reason why you never
ever-- freedive alone 99% of blackouts
and freediving which are rare in
recreational diving happen within about
5 to 7 feet of the surface if you have
someone there that grab you take you up
you're gonna be just fine if you don't
then you can be in serious trouble so it
is a danger and that's why I don't feel
like I should I should be speaking about
you know the 20 different things you
should be doing before free diving take
a course with an experienced person if
you want to do this and learn all the
safety first and how common is I mean
are there other courses there there's
becoming like a lot of courses of
starting up mostly in San Diego where
you can do this stuff you know a lot of
people app dive and you hear about how
dangerous AB diving is it's because
these people have never taken a course
in free diving they don't know what's
really what it's Oh abalone diving sorry
abalone has nothing to do with your
abdomen
maybe there is something all diving that
downtown but I don't know about it
another question back there
[Music]
well I think it's only been until very
recently that we haven't needed to to
use diving you look at cultures around
the world and every culture that was by
the ocean was free diving almost every
culture I mean even up into the Baltic
Sea there's evidence of free diving
cultures that dates back 10,000 years so
you know it's just in the last about a
hundred years that we've developed
fishing technologies - that made have
made free diving obsolete you know up
until around fifty years ago there were
still many japanese ama divers diving
and greek sponge divers so i you know my
understanding of how genetics forces can
take thousands and thousands and
thousands of years
also with echolocation this is something
i took a course little 30-minute course
with brian bush way and was able to
easily tell the difference between wood
and glass and plaster and coroner's I
mean it just clicks on very very quickly
so I think we're a long way off from
from forgetting all these things as far
as kind of the evolutionary biology the
developmental line of this are there has
that connection been made before that
hey we can survive you know we can
handle going to these depths because you
we're in we're in liquids you know
that's like the ocean in the womb
kind of thing is that is that something
that's that you would you found sources
that had already kind of made that
connection or is that something I think
well well yeah there's been a lot of
research into mammalian dive reflex
they've been researching it since the
50s and they found it in so many other
animals and right now you know they're
doing a lot of research with humans
because these scientists will make will
say the deepest we could possibly go is
500 feet and someone dives a 600 feet
and they're like okay the deepest we can
possibly go is 650 feet and then I saw a
guy dived at 800 feet so so we keep
reprising this because we just don't
know
the human body's potential in water yet
we're not even close to understanding it
so this isn't something to answer your
question this isn't something I made up
there's a long line of research that
many people are doing at this time so
the subheading of your book is
renegade science that's right talk for a
minute about how it's a renegade what
the scientific establishment there's
clearly some tension between the
establishment of these guys yeah one of
one of the main guys I write about his
name is Fabrice Knoller and he was
sailing out off the coast of Mauritius
about seven years ago and he saw some
whales and didn't know anything about
well so he hopped in the water and he
heard that clicking and he thought it
was coming from a motor on the boat and
then he looked down and he noticed there
were whales surrounding him clicking at
him and he stayed in the water for about
four hours with these animals and just
had this you know he's this french guy
he's like mind-blowing New Age
experience so since then he tried to
work with a bunch of he's probably gonna
listen to this Fabrice I love you thank
you but uh he he tried to work with a
bunch of the universities and a bunch of
different researchers and they just had
no interest so he started his own
research group yes he has a scientific
background he was he had a lumber store
and he quit doing that and he was just
he's possessed with trying to figure out
these animals so he's very good lumber
behind he his left lumber behind yes he
but you know he's very good at
collecting data he's not too good at
analyzing it which is why he's gotten
acoustic scientists from the French Navy
and all that to help analyze the data
but just very quickly in that few years
that he's been collecting data with
freediving doing this free diving
approach he has more sperm whale and
dolphin footage of communication than
anyone else on the planet so um that
just kind of goes to show you how
effective this mode of research when he
first came he was free diving or he was
just it sounded like you said he was
just kind of he was at the surface but
but something amazing I was like they're
they're cool with you when you're
snorkeling with them but they get really
excited when you're able to dive down
about 50 feet and interact with them
down there and that's when they really
stick around and you said that if
somebody goes down with scuba gear or
robots they respond
very negatively scuba is is very
disruptive to them and it's very loud
and so usually they're not gonna stick
around most almost all of the time
they're not about free diving almost all
the time they see you they're gonna turn
around and interact with you there's a
yeah rebreathers are great and there's a
lot of new technology with them right
now the problem is when you're on these
research expeditions you I mean it looks
like Manny just go out to the ocean you
just dive with these whales like I want
to do it I don't know the real story is
like ten days in a row on a teeny boat
with eight other people in the Sun
without shade looking for whales so when
it happens when you see them you have to
act very quickly got to put on your mask
and get in the water immediately so
rebreathers take a long time to prepare
there's a lot of little things that can
go wrong and they can be really
dangerous if you're not meticulous we
breather will clean the carbon dioxide
out of the air that that you and and
will create more oxygen so it's
essentially like a scuba tank but it's a
closed system so you wouldn't need to if
you had a rebreather you could keep keep
exhaling and inhaling no problem it's
just they're quite large they're little
cumbersome they're hard to take two very
strange places and you need to be you
know very quick but there are some
photographers some of these shots were
shot by a guy who uses a rebreather so
yeah right there
[Music]
really good question so how do you do
citizen science and crowd source towards
this the science that's going on
renegade and citizen science totally
interchangeable we thought renegade
science found it better for the book
title so we use that but he's
essentially a citizen scientist doing
this what's enabled him to do all of
this stuff is because technology is so
cheap right now he's making all of his
own rigs out of stuff he buys off at
eBay you know ten years ago even five
years ago a lot of this wouldn't be
possible so he is trying to incorporate
many other citizen freediving scientists
to contribute towards this research his
site is Darwin dot org and you can look
it up online and see what he's doing
he's always looking for volunteers so
what he's doing is trying to find a rig
or produce a rig that anyone can wear
that will be able to record these clicks
in a certain way that that scientists
can actually use them and would you say
his next step is publicizing it getting
things out in the media or is is a
publishing research or making a
connection into a more formal research
kind of what'swhat's this goal right now
absolutely everything's gonna be
peer-reviewed that's what the actual
researchers at the University of Paris
are doing right now they're making sure
all of this stuff is bulletproof because
it's so insane so before he really comes
out right now they're just researching
researching researching trying to
establish the software get all the
hardware set up and and just to collect
more data and
his focus is predominantly on on the
whales themselves not on the human
aspects of it I mean there are there is
clearly this is pushing boundaries as
far as what we understand about how
humans can go underwater but is it is
that pretty much mostly in terms of the
extent to which we can stay under
there's he just uses free diving
casually as a tool it's an effective
tool and that's it there are other
people pushing boundaries at the
Karolinska Institute they're doing a lot
of research into the mammalian dive
reflex there's one guy who has developed
this new way of free diving on empty
lungs
so if you think it's hard to dive with a
breath of air imagine doing it with no
air at all on you he says that this
allows you to go deeper because you
don't have that exchange of I tried it
once and it sucked so I'm probably not
gonna do it so there there are people
doing a bunch of research into the
mammalian dive reflex there we go so so
the books been out you said about three
months about three months yeah how long
did it take to write it and is the book
you thought you were did you start this
process at where you were at in this
process you're like okay I need to write
this book about free diving in Tibet
what not at all I had no intention of
writing a book about free diving or
whales or dolphins or any of that but
after Greece I remember talking to my
agent said oh there might be a book here
and we were able to sell the nonfiction
book and of course the publisher got
excited and wanted a one-year turnaround
I don't know if you know too much about
nonfiction book writing but it usually
takes three or four years and I was very
arrogant I said oh of course no problem
and I could do it while holding my
breath we please watch this so it took
18 months and nine months of that was
spent traveling so I'm catch it been
catching up on sleep ever since then so
it was a very quick year-and-a-half book
from start to finish till when it was
delivered so and it's been out for about
three months yeah is there any any more
percent of what you you touched on in
the talk about the the bank
a sense in humans is that something
there's a lot more but I didn't want to
totally bore everyone with the specifics
there's a lot more in the book as well
they've found I'll just give you one
little yeah one little piece so about
two years ago researchers found a
protein in the human eye called the h
cry 2 protein that is Magneto
receptive and from that they were saying
this has probably been used for you know
years and years and years to help us
orient towards magnetic north what
happens when the polar shift happens you
know comes and that's when magnetic
north will shift to magnetic South who
knows it might be mean broad extinction
for everyone who has magnetic reception
but I guess we'll have to wait and see
so was anyone here for our endangered
language talk that we had a lot of our
staff so so actually I think there were
two topics here some of the the clicking
the clicking languages which is I don't
know if we've confirmed there's direct
connection with the echolocation but
certainly if there's some suggestions of
that and then the cardinal languages
with which and another talk in this
series we talked about let's have one
last question there's somebody who's
read the book that's right there okay
well this is sure I'll try to recap this
very quickly is a very long story John
Lilly was a Nero physiologist at the
National Institute of Mental Health that
created something called the sensory
deprivation tank now it's been rebranded
as the float tank because that sounds
better so he got very interested in
dolphins he was convinced they knew how
to talk and ran a battery of amazing
tests with the Navy and one test they
claim to have deciphered and translated
242 words of dolphin whistle into
English and then back again and then it
gets very weird a bunch of conspiracy
theorists come in the guy who did this a
lot of this work with lily was a Harvard
scientist suddenly died and the reports
went missing forever and and then Lily
got really into LSD and started shooting
dolphins up with LSD and trying to have
dolphin English language immersion
workshops which totally worked so they
they worked and then he got so depressed
he knew how intelligent these animals
were their brains are bigger than ours
he got so depressed that he let all the
dolphins free and said I'm never gonna
do this again
and he at that time completely destroyed
the field of interspecies communication
with all of his research and it took
about 35 to 40 years for it to come back
and it's just barely scraping back but
it's all under the pall of Lily's
shooting up dolphins with LSD and
holding dolphin emergen length language
workshops so these legitimate
researchers are just having to
constantly fight against this new age
storm that seems to push in from all
directions to do real legitimate science
in dolphin communication all right well
that's an amazing maid's place to end
this so thank you everyone you've been a
fantastic audience let's have one more
round of applause for Jane
thanks a lot
[Music]
you